las vegas known for being the
entertainment cap of the world and now
also has one of the most instagrammable
places
colorful dishes beautiful scenery sally
jaramillo shows us a one of a kind
perspective
becca is kind of our hidden little
secret over here in southern highlands
you can find this gem at the tuscan
highlands apartment community
stephen kennedy is the managing partner
it's a
american italian sports bar with about
34 televisions to watch games
full bar liquor beer draft beer wine
and it also has a 10 000 square foot
patio
lots of amenities here for community
come down and enjoy
indoor and outdoor diving kennedy and
his team wanted to create a community
inside a complex with an atmosphere that
will make you
keep coming back we have a wine garden
that has about 40 tables
we have a custom wine cart that we built
in and brought in from
tuscan italy we host events out there on
the weekends with some charcuterie and
wine
and different you know specialty
cocktails
even music becca is family friendly
and is attracting tourists the la
commute people are definitely popping in
and catching us on the way
in and on the layout we created this
resort style living bringing
a unique destination to las vegas
beautiful patio views fire pits we have
a little garden wall with instagram
photo opportunity we've got hand-painted
murals inside the venue
but it doesn't stop there in the evening
as the sun sets over the mountain behind
us here it's beautiful some great photo
ops so
come down and get that instagram picture
sally jaramillo reporting from las vegas
becca's restaurant is well known for its
sunday brunch as well